all right this is a candy crush so i got
a level
40 walk through with commentary
um
adding it to our guide uh
have been having some people
who are still having trouble with this
level in our group so i was just adding
some additional tips
if you haven't read our guide i would
suggest doing that
it explains the best strategy
and
to briefly
go over that i guess the you know the
key here is that or the problem here is
is that we don't have any space
um
we're gonna need a big combo or two
to rescue all the bears
so we need to create space in the
beginning as the the priority
so that we can we'll have more
opportunity to make
combos
i did notice when i fired this up this
morning
i haven't hadn't played it for a while
and i noticed that they did
actually make it easier
they took off some of the top layers
there so that's that's good
it used to used to have a whole bunch
more um our original video you know if
you watch that you'll see
it was even harder
back then but
the strategy is the same and that's
what's important
um
you know we want to make specials
and we want to
basically
make combos
because
that's what's going to actually
get rid of all the blockers so that we
can get
um
all the bears
and you could kind of see that i am
i i had this
here i've had this here for a while i
was just kind of
i wanted to use up the color bomb and
stuff first just so i could get maximum
damage whenever i
made this combo here
you know some situations you won't want
to get too technical but that one was
pretty straightforward so i think it was
a the best way to go about that part
and it did actually help us out as far
as
you know we have a lot of stuff
damaged so we just have to get a little
bit more we need another strike or
something here
and we'll you know you'll see as the
board opens up we'll have a lot more
chances to um
put together combinations
uh you know in general you want to work
towards the bottom
because that'll be where you're going to
be making things but always look up top
first before
to make sure you don't miss anything
and
don't worry so much about fish
fish are great on some levels and when i
first played this i i'm i kind of was
like still the fish was new and i was
see i missed a uh color bomb up there
because i was paying attention to the
bottom
hopefully that won't come back to haunt
me
but yeah the fish
on this type of level they don't
they don't do much except to take off
one layer or one piece of ice so
you don't want to make waste moves
making them
i need a color bomb
so let's see if i can't make one
that's not gonna work
that's not gonna work
i guess we'll go with the um wrapped
there we go
all right so getting these two together
would be great
i'm not sure if we'll be able to do that
but that's what i'm going to look to try
to do
there's actually no matches underneath
there at all is there
so we got 11 moves um we still have five
bears
that sort of gives you that that sort of
shows you the importance of getting
the combinations um you know there's
really no way to through matches or
through single fish or anything like
that that you're going to be able to
get the rest of the bears
so you know that's why that's why i
emphasize it in the guide that you know
the main thing that you want to do
is set up some combos
so
now we have this
but we don't have anything to go along
with it
and that's what i'm trying to do is give
it something to match up with that
that green one's blocking us from making
the fish there
this is a fish but
that green one's still getting away
if you're not sure um if you're
wondering why you know the fish when you
match it with the color bomb
is a great match
all right so
in the process of setting that one up
since our board was open
we were lucky enough to set up a
different combo instead
there is a problem here
in that there's not very many blue
pieces on the board but this is our last
bear right here at this point so
even though the there's no blue ones
that are going to hit it directly it
will create a pretty nice cascade
hopefully and
that'll be good enough
and yeah so now we can get rid of it
another point that i wanted to make from
the guide is that the the fish are
pretty pointless on this type of level
because they don't go after like we have
one square so you would think
if you activate a fish it would go where
the bear is but it doesn't do that on
ice levels it does it on honey levels
uh which will come in handy later but
you know
the fish by themselves really won't help
you unless there's only one
piece of ice on the board um or you know
your your chances go up if there's
less pieces ice you know
so that's how you beat the level
um
just check out the guide if you want
some more clarification on how to um
how to approach it from start to finish
please like the video if you find it
helpful
make sure you visit our site
candycrush.sagatips.com
to learn about how everything works
and we have guides on the how the how
the specials work and different level
types more commentary videos on the
tough levels
plus written tips
so make sure you check us out and
good luck with the game thanks